There are a lot of Republicans, though,
who are not cautious at all.
In fact,
they've thrown caution to the winds.
Some are not only proclaiming Trump's
complete innocence,
not knowing obviously,
the fact pattern here,
but also calling for Bragg
to be indicted and jailed.
Rand Paul is one of them.
He tweeted,
and I quote,
A Trump indictment
would be a disgusting abuse of power.
The D.A. should be put in jail All right.
So then he was asked on camera,
well, jail's a big thing to say.
How come you feel this way, Senator?
And here's what he said.
In your mind.
What floor did he break?
Where he made me to go to jail.
I think we'll stick with just what
we tweeted out
you on a report
that Senator
Paul Woodward did
did the Alvin Bragg break
that needs to go to jail.
Why do you think he needs to be in jail?
Senator Bob
Senator Paul, what
did you mean by your tweet
that you thought the Manhattan D.A.
should be jailed?
Senator Paul,
what did you mean by your tweet?
That the Manhattan D.A.
should be found
So, Jonah, no answer.
Obviously, Rand Paul
doesn't know the full facts of the case.
No one does a lawyer sitting here.
I don't know
exactly what Bragg has or does not have.
Is Senator Paul's
call for Bragg
to be jailed over the line or not?
It's silly. It's stupid.
It's boob bait and fan service.
For a Twitter audience.
Is it?
But I think, you know,
if you take a step back,
it is a piece with this larger
dynamic, right,
where Donald Trump comes
to Washington, gets elected
president, violates all sorts of norms.
You know,
forget laws for a second,
just like
norms, traditions, customs, probity.
He violates at all bull in a china shop,
and that gives permission to his enemies
to violate norms,
to go beyond, to go
too far, to go,
you know,
go for the jugular, to do politics
as the crow flies
rather than go through
the right processes.
And now we have this tit
or tit for tat thing
where it's elicited
what I think is
I agree entirely
with Van Jones
that this is a
fraught case
to bring first
against the former president,
the United States.
But you had a prosecutor run for office
saying he's going to go
after Donald Trump,
which is a norm violation, too.
And then you've got people
responding to that.
There's a
right wing
radio guy, just Kelly, talking
about how you have to start
indicting all the Democrats.
This is the kind of eye for an eye logic
that Trump brings in
and he
brings out the worst in his enemies.
I love the politics as the crow
flies analogy.
Hope, Jonah, I'll credit you on it,
but I only use that one again
because it says something right.
Norms matter, right?
Norms and rules matter.
And FAA matters.
So. So, Karen, here's the thing, though.
The conversation that we're having
that you can go
and watch a Fox point of view right now
or an MSNBC point of view now.
And these jurors could do that.
They're not sequestered.
They're 23 people.
They are,
you know,
in the midst of this media
media storm as well.
Is that concerning Yeah, of course it is.
I mean, it's it's very concerning.
But hopefully they will
they are instructed
to only listen to the evidence
and only consider the evidence.
And hopefully that's
what they're doing here.
And frankly,
if if they can't
if this doesn't get indicted,
given the lower standard probable cause,
then they would never make it
beyond a reasonable doubt.
So it's good to do this
now, put all the evidence in now.
And if they can get an indictment,
then it goes forward.
If not, then it shouldn't have.
So.
So, Brian,
that now back to what
we heard Joe Tacopina say. Right.
Talking about
this is a Pandora's
box is all bad for the president.
Now that was in 2018
you saw I'm talking to Don
Lemon there
in law coats and again 2018 that's
when Stormy Daniels
was maybe looking for representation
so maybe that's what he was
the audience he was speaking to
but and he didn't have the facts
he has now
I mean it just doesn't look right
his whole takeaway is
this is terrible for the president
now he's the guy going on the airwaves
day after day.
He is the defense attorney
for the president.
Yeah.
He did a bunch of interviews
and a lot of appearances on
CNN in 2018 around that time.
He made other statements as well.
A lot of people were saying like
this raises certain campaign
finance issues,
which he is saying
you know, Dimon,
he was the one who was bringing that
into the conversation.
Yeah.
Which that's the that's
the strategy argument here,
which is
does this actually raise the hush money
count as a campaign contribution?
There he is on TV saying it does.
And now he's saying the opposite.
And it's
very unusual
for somebody to be doing that.
And it's also very unusual
because he also said on CNN
that he was consulted by Stormy Daniels.
He said that in 2018
and he
refused to answer
certain questions, saying
attorney client privilege
because of that consultation.
And it's amazing
that he's now in this position.
All right.
So Van
Trump obviously is, you know,
raising money off of all this.
You know, there's the reporting
that he wants to be handcuffed.
You know,
he thinks it's all great for them.
At least he's pretending.
He thinks that it's all great for him.
Yeah.
If they
don't indict, obviously,
that that's a win
for him in certain ways.
And if they do,
he thinks it's a win for him
in other ways.
Yeah.
Is it a win win?
Well, you know,
that means it's Wednesday.
You know,
that's that's the Donald
Trump phenomenon.
Like, whatever happens,
he figures out some way
to make it work for him.
He's he's like he's like a
like a sinister Ferris Bueller.
You know,
he just gets away with stuff
and it just drives people nuts.
But the idea that he's
fundraising off of this,
what about the false advertising?
He says, I'm
going to get arrested on Tuesday.
Send me money, everybody.
Everybody's in the money.
He's not arrested.
I mean, he's just he's unbelievable
the stuff he gets away with. Right.
I mean, Joan is I mean,
he did say he was being arrested.
On Tuesday. Yeah.
Yeah.
And look,
I think short term,
this helps them
to sort of rally
around him thing
that happens
sort of like
what happened with Mar a Lago.
But I think long term,
this is probably really bad for him
because it fuels this feeling of man.
There's just always something
with this guy
and like it fuels this idea
that there's drama,
that he invites these problems
and that the amount of baggage
he would have.
Because remember,
if they indicted more now,
they're also going to
probably indict them
for the Georgia stuff. Right.
And then for the federal stuff.
And that's a lot of indictments.
That's just a lot of drip, drip, drip.
And at some point,
you can see people saying look,
I think they're treated unfairly,
but there's just
it's just too much muchness
with this guy.
Let's get a clean, fresh start again.
Too much muchness.
Politics as the crow flies Okay.
Thank you all so much. I appreciate it.